- Do you know how many people
that are listening right now
did a large transaction with somebody
and after that transaction,
have never interacted with
that person ever again?
I believe that,
and that's why that just
resonated with all of you, right?
You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
- So I wanna welcome everybody
to the Mortgage Marketing Expert Podcast.
We are a proud founding member
of the industry syndicate.
Our mortgage marketing expert today
is none other than the
man, Gary Vaynerchuck.
Man I appreciate you so
much for having us here.
- I appreciate that.
- It's been a long time coming,
obviously agent 2021, finally
got to make this happen.
Our audience is in large
part mortgage professionals,
some real estate professionals,
and a lot of that audience
is starting to consume your content,
but not all of them have seen you yet.
So really what I wanna
to to add value to them,
the most value that I can add is time,
I wanna kind of curate some of the content
that I may know the answers
to, or some of them,
but just kind of put it in one place.
- [Gary] Happy to do it.
- So the average age of
originator is late 40s, early 50s.
That group of people didn't
grow up with social media,
didn't necessarily do the
mortgage industry that way,
so as far as focusing
on personal branding,
what advice do you have
to that group of people
that doesn't find this kind
of thing all that natural?
- I think that that group
understands reputation.
The amount of 40 to 50 year olds
that dominate in mortgage and real estate,
on 100% model of word of mouth reputation
of the work they put in for
the last 20 years is very high.
And when I hear the word personal brand,
and when a lot of people
hear the word personal brand,
they think it's a douchy term.
They think there's a stigma to that term,
yet when I hear it, I just
hear the word reputation.
And ironically 49 year old Donny,
who thinks personal brand is doof shit
of like 22 year olds,
when he or she hears reputation,
they take a totally different
point of view on it.
So just to set the tone right away,
the reason to make content on LinkedIn,
on Facebook, on these platforms
is to build scaled reputation.
What, you think it's impossible
that you put out a video on LinkedIn
that gives somebody a smart tidbit
that's seen by somebody in Alabama
who happens to be the sister
of somebody that's in
your residential area
who says do you know this guy?
Do you know this girl?
And then that leads to your
lead gen to close a deal.
Just so everybody knows
who doesn't know me,
or knows me, but doesn't understand,
I'm out here talking about things
that drive business results.
Like I happen to believe
they come from things
like providing value,
and understanding where the
customer's attention is.
The same reason your grand
pappy called your firm
Triple A Mortgage,
is because he understood
that the yellow pages
had all the attention,
and if you named your
company Triple A Mortgage,
you showed up first,
and more people called the first
number in the yellow pages.
All I'm doing is that same move
on LinkedIn and Facebook.
- I love that.
What about those people that say I don't.
- We could end this podcast right now.
- We absolutely could, that was gold.
- I mean it though.
If you're a logical, unemotional,
non-demonizer of technology,
and are willing to be self-aware enough
that you just actually
don't wanna put in the work,
not that you don't
think it actually works,
and you heard what I just said
for the last three minutes,
this is a wrap.
This is a very basic model
of something that is historically true,
as far back as you go.
Somebody drew the best pictures in caves.
Somebody had the best forearms
to do the most smoke signals
on the top of a fuckin' mountain.
Somebody was born with the gift of a voice
that was the right one to
read a radio ad in 1937.
I'm not doing anything new,
I'm just doing it best
in the thing that is right now.
To sell mortgages, to sell homes
to sell B2B shopping
complexes, selling it out,
to sell sneakers and wine,
to change people's opinions on
what an alpha male should be,
to talk about modern
parenting vulnerabilities,
to pontificate about my dear
love of the New York Jets,
and everything else that
comes through my fucking mind,
but this is contextual communications
at scale for the world
we actually live in,
not the one that you built your career on.
For example, how can your
picture on a bench bus ad
be worth the same
when every single passenger on earth now
is looking at their phone
when they're driving?
By theory, it should be 35% less in cost.
By just common sense,
you should be paying 35%
less for your bench ad today
than you did eight years ago,
because now 100% of passengers
are looking at their phone.
Drivers are not even looking at the road.
- Truth.
No that's.
- Stuff like that.
And now while you're listening,
and you're yelling, or
thinking in your mind,
yeah Gary but my direct mail works.
I'm like cool Sally,
but if you spent that same $11,000 dollars
on Facebook properly,
I'll get you more leads.
You know why?
Because I still do direct mail
for my dad's liquor store in New Jersey.
And I run them against
swipe up ads on Instagram,
I know the math.
I'm not pontificating off of theory.
Every person right now who's listening,
who says this stuff doesn't
work isn't actually doing it.
Or they did it once for
$500 bucks on Facebook,
they put out a piece of
shit ad, it didn't work,
and they decided it was Facebook's fault.
That's like me blaming a
basketball for not being Lebron.
You like that one Zane?
That was good right?
That's a better way to say
the thing I usually say.
I like that, clip that shit Dustin.
- One of the first
pieces of content that I,
several years ago, really
made the connection
with this guy Gary V,
was you were talking
about boards of directors,
and leaderships within companies
that have been doing it
one way for 30 years,
and are on their way out,
and don't necessarily have the motivation
to learn a new skillset,
or to put a lot of
dollars and cents to it,
and that's been very much
the mortgage industry
for the last few years.
They've used excuses of compliance,
or dollars, or whatever else.
And so the people that
are having challenges
with their companies and
leadership think like that.
- Ironically though, I apologize,
Rocket Mortgage and Zebra
and all these other people
are not struggling with those same issues.
And oh by the way, let's talk
about the elephant in the room
are fucking dominating.
Why are we having this conversation?
- Agreed.
- This is like literally the conversations
I'm having with network television,
debating at OTT doesn't work.
Do you live in life?
Do you understand not one person
doesn't watch Netflix or Hulu?
And by the way, that's without Warner,
Disney X just came out,
Apple's just coming out,
Peacock's coming from NBC,
fuckin', we haven't even started.
Wait til' I drop Vayner OTT.
I'm gonna take a million subscriptions.
You're never gonna see this
content again for free.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Not really, but yes.
- That's good stuff.
So being a loan officer
is a lot like you talking
about being a business owner,
being a firefighter,
that's a huge challenge,
and a lot of sales, marketing,
entrepreneur type things.
What are some tips you can give folks
as far as wearing that firefighter hat
and still effectively
building their business?
- Well being a firefighter
is the business.
- Great distinction.
- If you're interested in
living a life that you want,
what comes, the great,
do you know how fun it
is to be my employees?
They can blame me.
You know how fun it is to blame Andy?
It's somebody above you,
like well his content is stupid,
that's why it's not working.
And then they're like wait a minute,
but actually Gary, it's Gary's fault,
it's so fun to be an employee.
It's super not fun to be,
you know everything is
actually your fault.
If there's like a leak in
my office in Long Island.
I remember last year, like when they,
heat doesn't work.
Or when I change my strategy
on the snacks we're using
and everyone decides I'm
the worst human ever.
Or whatever it is, everything is my fault.
Everything is my fault.
But that's what I chose to do.
If you want the fuckin' accolades,
you gotta eat the shit
that comes along with it.
And the more shit you can eat,
the more likely the accolades get bigger.
- So good, it's so important.
- So if you don't want the fires,
be an employee, and enjoy yourself.
- I love that.
- But that's what it is.
It's about making choices
and dealing with the ramifications.
How could you possibly get
the glory without the work?
Like how is that possible?
Why have people thought,
how, how have we gotten into a place
where people believe
that you can be successful
without bleeding?
And bleeding comes in a lot of forms.
Some people it's 15 hours a day.
Some people it's nine hours a day,
but nine highly stressful,
to me it's less about hours,
it's more about stomach.
What can your stomach handle?
Can you deal with the scrutiny?
you know how not fun it is to be me
in a world where I hate being disliked?
And every day thousands of people
are actively putting out the information
to say they dislike me on social?
That requires a stomach.
- As opposed to being grateful
that people are actually look
at you in the first place.
- Yeah, and by the way,
I'm not a buyer of all
publicity is good publicity.
When somebody thinks I'm a Charlton
or a snake oil salesman,
I don't like that mention.
Like all awareness is not equal.
It's ludacris that all publicity
is good publicity, really?
Just not interested.
I don't want, that's not true.
- What's your take on
mortgage real estate,
the industry as a whole?
You had a really cool perspective
with Agent 2021 about the
direction the industry's heading.
I'd love for you to kind
of expand on that share.
- I think the internet eats up everything,
and if you do not know how,
and I do not think it eliminates
everybody who has a job,
I think it eliminates people
who do not bring value.
And what I said at Agent 2021 I mean,
which is if I started a Vayner brokerage,
right now I would win
because people wanna build
their personal brands.
Not pay higher.
If I come out with lower
fees than the market,
and offer the ability to
build up your personal brand
along the way,
how am I not gonna kill everybody?
- You will, you absolutely will.
- I'm probably not gonna do it,
because I'm super not interested in it.
But somebody else is going to.
And it's about providing value.
This is one big game of value.
The reason I will always win
is I inherently know
that I'm only interested
in providing value to the customer,
and everything else is secondary.
That's it.
- That's so awesome,
and I think it's important,
the feedback that you
get from your consumer.
I was recently listening
to one of your podcasts
where you're talking about the consumer
is who you listen to.
You don't pay attention
to anybody else's content,
you're just observing the consumer
and consumer behavior,
and that drives your actions.
- If you think I've done the homework
to know that these upstart
mortgage companies are doing well
because I've actually done the homework
you're out of your mind.
I know it because I read comments.
I know what people talk about.
It's the same reason
I know who Da Baby is,
and the same reason I know
every single five-star quarterback
who's fuckin' 12 right now,
and the same reason I know that TikTok
is on its verge of going mainstream,
it's all the same game.
That's why my contents good,
I know what to talk about
because I know what
people are interested in.
I'm good because I listen.
Everybody thinks I just talk
because I interrupt, I talk all the time,
produce so much content,
that's the manifestation
of the better listening.
It's why I always have ideas.
I always have ideas because
I'm in perpetual listening.
It's easy to have ideas
when you're listening.
You don't even have ideas,
you're just fulfilling needs.
You think I wanted to
talk about parenting?
It didn't even cross my fuckin' mind.
It's just getting a billion fuckin' DM's
that are like but my mom this,
and my mom that, and my dad this,
I'm like oh fuck, right,
that's why you're not posting.
That's why you're not doing what you want.
Your dad told you you have to be a lawyer,
and you don't know how
to think any other way.
Especially 'cause you,
and then you start playing
chess, not checkers.
Oh right, it's not
because your dad fuckin'
put you into some weird coma,
it's that you still want
dad to pay for your stuff.
You value your Equinox and
Uber and fuckin' Yeezy so much
that you're willing to live a life
that doesn't make you happy.
So you're still on the payroll,
and what dad wants is
for you to be a lawyer.
Now I understand.
And that's how I laevigate.
- Absolutely, so to drill down on that,
for real estate and mortgage
professionals specifically,
if they have a couple hundred followers,
and they're commenting and reading,
what do they need to
be paying attention to?
What should they focus
on to kind of understand?
- Well first at the small of a scale,
anything they get,
which is not gonna be a whole lot.
It's probably like your
aunt saying go Rick.
So you're not gonna get shit from that.
What you probably wanna do
is consume other people's content.
You probably wanna go in to five to 15
meaningful Facebook groups
that talk about this.
You definitely wanna join
your local community.
Do you know how many people
built their entire business
on being part of the
local chamber of commerce,
but refused to get a Facebook account
and join a Facebook group about the town?
Do you know how fuckin' stupid that is.
You're religious about the idea
of doing all these community,
literally 90% of the people
that are listening right now
are focused on doing community tactics.
I'm gonna sponsor the softball team.
I'm gonna walk the fuckin' parade.
I'm gonna join the PTA.
I'm gonna fuckin' join
the chamber of commerce.
I'm gonna start the
small business alliance.
I'm gonna walk for fuckin' nine hours
down Main Street to all
13 stores eight times.
All for the ability to
hand their business card
to somebody with the hope
that they use them
versus what I would do,
which is I'm gonna watch TV,
lay in my fuckin' underwear,
open my phone, be in the community
fuckin' page on Facebook,
join the community
and talk about the high
school football team,
or Karen, or the fuckin'
pothole on Main Street,
and get four times more fuckin' business
than your fuckin' idiotic
waste of 8,000 fuckin' hours
in the local community fuckface.
- (laughing) Yes.
- What are we talking about here?
There's the blueprint
everyone, there you go.
I just gave it to you.
Do that, join the Facebook groups
that are local to your town.
Go in there and don't be a spam bot,
and just say use me, use me,
actually be a normal citizen
like I just painted you were
by doing all those lovely things you do.
You understand that,
but you refused to do
what I just told you,
which would triple your business
and give you a lot more
time to do stuff you want.
'Cause I think a lot of you are hustling,
and you don't want to actually
go to the town,
the main street fucking open,
small business Saturday weekend.
And you'd actually rather
go play soccer with you kid.
You'd rather go on a
date with your husband.
But that's how you actually do business
because you refuse to realize it's 2020.
That's my life, that's what I think about.
- Love it.
I think there's so many people
that needed to hear that,
and I appreciate you sharing that.
'Cause you get the same old answers
is what content do I create?
When do I have time to create it?
What do I talk about?
What's the audience say?
- Every single person
listening here right now
wastes 40% of their time on dumb shit.
When, when you're not
sitting in your office
waiting for the phone to ring.
How about then?
How about you create content then?
What the hell are you doing?
You've put busy work on a pedestal,
not results driven work.
Just 'cause you work 11 hours a day, cool.
You could waste 11 hours in a heartbeat.
Not to mention if you actually audit it,
you actually spent 72
minutes watching my content,
you actually spent 15 minutes
going back and forth
with your friend on text
debating tonight's Thursday night game.
Like I'm actually working.
My team's stressed when I'm like
one minute off on something.
That's actually real life.
Like we're fuckin' scrambling.
You should see my poor admins out there.
They're a mess.
- When we walked in they're like
is he starting right now?
Like I need 30 seconds.
- It's literally every minute.
So I know what the extreme is,
and I don't recommend that for everybody,
that's just, you found your perfect,
I found my crescendo.
I found my fuckin' perfect spot.
Where my talents meet my happiness.
Not everyone's gonna do that,
but don't tell me you don't have time.
- So I wanna talk about that for a minute,
because one of my coaches
talks about ROI versus ROE,
return on energy, and where that genius is
is finding things that are ROI positive,
but also feed you energy.
That's kind of the space that you live in.
- I like the way that person framed it.
Yes I understand that.
Because it also is a perpetuate machine.
If you're happy, it's gonna
make you wanna work more.
I put out a post yesterday,
or a couple days ago,
that really resonated.
It's the first time I said it.
I said I actually don't
think anyone's lazy.
I don't think you're lazy,
I think you're showing yourself
that you don't like it.
And I know what that looks like,
that's why I have a terrible report card.
Like I know exactly what
not wanting to do something manifests in.
Poor results.
- So another direction
I wanna kind of go in
is sales versus marketing.
Marketing is getting someone's attention,
sales is actually closing the deal
and making them a customer.
What is your take on that whole concept?
- I spend 90% of my energy on marketing.
And everybody thinks they're marketing
and then they're spending
100% of their time on sales.
- Are you finding that
most sales industries
are lazy compared to what
they were 10-20 years ago.
- No, I think they're basic.
I think they're basic.
They think the sale is,
that's their religion,
it's the number right now.
And they're not thoughtful.
They don't understand the expense of it.
I understand that when I send
a second text for wine text,
that a lot of people
are gonna unsubscribe,
but I made more sales.
So yeah I got 360 more bottles,
but at what cost?
I just lost 44 people that will never buy.
People don't think.
People think in CAC,
customer acquisition cost.
They don't think in LTV.
Do you know how many people
that are listening right now
did a large transaction with somebody
and after that transaction
have never interacted with
that person ever again?
I believe that,
and that's why that just
resonated with all of you.
Why don't you send somebody a $23 dollar
fuckin' fruit basket with a nice card
that maybe references some
moment during your interactions
when you saw the pretty bird.
Or you spilled coffee on yourself.
To show them you actually are human,
which then will actually lead to
maybe them referring you to somebody else.
You're spending all your time
hunting for the other thing,
yet now that you got their commission,
and you signed 'em up, or
you sold 'em the house,
you never talked to them again.
That is 98% of the behavior
of 98% of the agents.
- So good.
- [Gary] Right?
- It is, it's just so true.
- Why don't you have a basic system
that sends somebody a nice gift
with a handwritten card,
because the gifts easy.
And then eventually it doesn't feel human.
With a handwritten card on
the one year anniversary
of the closing of your deal?
That happens to be the time
where I might just have
dinner with friends that night
and say somebody sent me a Jets pie today
that I did my fuckin' brokerage deal with.
And they're like oh,
actually we're in the market for,
we need mortgage, we need to refinance.
I'm like oh you have to go with Don,
he sends fuckin' Jets pies.
- Is a Jet pie a real thing?
- But no, everybody wants to cold call,
or direct mail, or fuckin',
I'm so fuckin'.
- And that's one of the reasons.
- The level of disrespect
I have for the other person
that's listening to this podcast right now
is enormously high,
and don't let disrespect come across mean,
it's just I'm just so passionate
to get people to do new shit.
- Get out of their comfort zone.
- Somebody's about to take your lunch.
- What I love so much of your content
is about understanding
and paying attention
to the most basic of human behaviors.
- [Gary] Correct.
- And understanding what it's about.
We talk about effective marketing
is the balance of trust and attention.
It's not good enough just to be out there
blasting yourself all over social media.
- And trust is an interesting word,
because I think it leads to behavior
that's a little one dimensional.
I think it's relevance.
- Relevance.
- So like trust can hurt people
because I believe when you say that,
people on the other side then start
with overselling themselves
to provide trust.
You see where I'm going?
- Absolutely.
- I'm thinking about Karen right now
who hears this, she's motivated,
she's like fuck it I'm making
my first LinkedIn video.
And she hears trust, which makes sense,
and I don't think,
I'm starting to learn that words
matter more than I thought.
People are pretty semantical.
When I hear trust as Karen
who just got motivated finally,
because I'm putting
pressure on the system.
And she's gonna make her LinkedIn video.
She hears trust, and she's gonna start
with a heavy sell up front.
I've been doing this for 23 years, right?
Where as meanwhile,
the way that Karen would
have gotten my business
is by making a reference to the Jets game
against the Eagles this weekend.
'Cause that's relevance.
Or, you know?
Or being an immigrant.
- Absolutely.
- Or liking root beer.
This is why I push people to
show every part of their lives.
You never know if it's heavy metal,
or it's growing up with immigrant parents,
or sports culture.
You don't know what the relevance is,
but there's always relevance.
- For sure.
- And the number one
advantage everybody has
on the other side of this,
is the most unique thing about you is you.
It is peeing your pants in second grade,
a story I've shared.
It is the way I became a Jets fan
because I needed something
to latch on to America,
something I shared.
My report card, something,
you know how many people follow me
because they sucked in high school too?
- It's relatable.
- Yes, it's relevance.
And it's true.
I like hip hop music, I like football,
notice how little I talk
about fuckin' video games.
I fuckin' am very aware
that video game culture
is a great content pillar
for me to play on.
But I have to share, when I do,
I have to share the I can beat everybody
in ice hockey for Nintendo,
because that's the last time
I was a gangster in video games.
19 fuckin' 87.
I don't talk about Fortnite,
I talk about the culture of Fortnite.
So you stay in your lane,
you stay around your passions,
and you build a community
around interests.
And then when you're localized
around that interest,
you put out a LinkedIn piece
of content around Zelda,
you sell mortgages in
fuckin' Des Moines, Iowa,
and you find yourself eight weeks later
in a coffee shop with 11 people
all dressed up as fuckin' Link and Peach,
and four days later you
closed your biggest deal.
That's way better than
a direct mail piece,
or a cold call, or fuckin' bench ad.
Here's why it's better,
because you had fun when you
dressed up as a mushroom.
- So I wanna be a good
steward of your time,
I wanna ask one last question
which we ask all of our guests,
is we talked about a lot of stuff,
but if you could just give one tip
to mortgage professionals today
to go out to use to build their business,
what would it be?
- Stop being audacious.
Your industry is audacious.
Bunch of people wearing suits
thinking they know something.
That's my advice.
Cut the audacity.
Everybody smart knows you're fuckin' lost.
Get your shit together, it's time.
If you do not produce content
for YouTube, LinkedIn,
and Facebook every day
as a real estate, and Instagram,
as a real estate or mortgage
professional, you're losing.
Figure it out.
That's a big statement,
I know that sounds scary.
You haven't posted anything,
and now I'm asking you four
fuckin' platforms a day,
go Google, go learn,
how do I post on YouTube?
I'm giving you the statement there,
I don't need to give
you tactics my friends,
it's called Google.
You don't know how to make a video?
Google.
I don't even know what final cup pro is,
I could figure everything they all do,
I could do in a day.
It's called Google.
Actually for me it's YouTube,
I can't read for shit.
I'd have to watch it.
But I'd know.
Keep yourself at,
God I hate fuckin',
I hate people that talk
something they don't live.
Plenty of leaders talking
about keep learning every day,
yet refuse to fuckin' learn.
Before I think we started the podcast,
'cause I don't think Ramef was here,
we talked about your
daughter knowing who I am.
I'm living my truth.
I tell you to keep doing
it, I keep doing it.
I've got a million followers on TikTok.
That's not fuckin' bragging
about my following on TikTok,
that's me living my fuckin' truth.
TikTok didn't even cross
my mind on January first.
- Well the reason it's so
cool from my perspective
is this legacy.
My daughters were able to consume
some of the content that I consume,
language and all,
and then on their platform
that was native to them,
they now appreciate who you are
and consume your content on
a completely different level
because to your point, the relevance.
TikTok is relevant to them,
that's the content that they consume.
- Correct.
And that's why I can go outside
and have a nine year old ask for a selfie,
and an 84 year old.
And that is.
- Incredible.
And I'm grateful,
and I want to, and I think for everybody,
if you stayed long enough,
if I haven't made you stop
listening with my energy,
all that energy, all that pressure,
all that cursing I just did,
that is a plea for you to be happy too.
I could care less if you do it or not.
As a matter of fact, for the record,
the number one great thing
in the short term for me
that could happen
is nobody listens to
anything I talk about,
because it's only one stream,
and we're all vying
for the same attention.
You're trying to sell a home?
I'm trying to get people
to sign up for wine text.
By the way, WineText.com, sign up.
- It'll be in the show notes as well,
just in case you missed that.
- [Gary] I appreciate that.
All right, I'm out of here.
- We appreciate you, thank
you so much, gratitude.
- Thank you bro, thank you so much.